welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler and I am
your one and only host for today's
episode uh if you watched the show last
week that was a solo episode as well of
course the advertisers are beating down
my door trying to get a piece of the
show uh the fan mail is absolutely
pouring in but some people have been
wondering what's up with the solo shows
uh people have even been speculating
that perhaps the holidays have made it
logistically difficult to coordinate
schedules and maybe that's why I've been
doing some shows solo rather than having
a co-host but nonetheless I want to put
some of these rumors to rest and I want
to come clean about Greg's absence in
this show and the prior show so as many
of our listeners know uh many months
back Greg spearheaded an effort to
unionize all of the stronger by science
podcast co-host both the present and
former Stronger by science podcast
co-host so during that effort I tried to
undermine that unionization through all
possible legal channels and some other
channels as well
nonetheless my efforts to undermine that
uh process were ultimately ineffective
and that Union did form and that brings
us to where we are today uh the stronger
by science podcast co-host Union wants
family contact to be reinstated one of
the policies of this show which is a an
industry standard policy is that if you
co-host a podcast you uh really
shouldn't be contacting friends or
family members and the reason for that
is in order to protect the show quality
and the focus of the show we want to
make sure that everybody is really all
in on the production so uh naturally we
tell people you know you have to cut off
contact with family and friends and like
I said that that's an industry standard
so now that this Union is meddling in
all of our business they want family
contact to be reinstated they might also
want friend contact to be reinstated but
it was really unclear in the
communications that I got so
um basically the bottom line is that I
refuse to be taken advantage of so those
negotiations are at a standstill and I
really don't see them budging much in
the near future so The Show Must Go On
uh today will be another solo episode
and we're going to be talking about
popular diets and some common
misconceptions in nutrition this is part
one of a two-part episode where we're
really going to look at a number of
popular diets and some really popular
nutrition myths and this is all part of
this bigger ongoing series of of
episodes where we're talking about some
really popular topics in nutrition you
know the the new year is coming up you
know we're getting to the final days of
December here people are really
strategically thinking about their diet
their nutrition and what they want to do
with their diet in the new year so it's
a really great opportunity to revisit
some of these popular topics and uh and
to discuss them in a high level of
detail so that's what we'll be doing for
today's episode but before we dive into
that content uh if you like the show and
you'd like to support it there are many
ways you can do that of course you can
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
podcasts you can join our email
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter we send out research updates
every single Wednesday which are very
concise very practical updates to help
you with your exercise and nutrition
goals if you're interested in one-on-one
virtual coaching we do offer that at
Stronger by science we have a very
talented team of coaches you can learn
more about that
at strongerbyscience.com coaching if you
want to get a discount on your
supplements you can do that at
bulksupplements.com we have a code which
is SBS pod or SBS pod if you enter that
code at checkout you get a five percent
discount on your entire order of course
you could subscribe to the mass research
review which we publish every single
month to keep you updated with the
newest research in exercise and
nutrition and you could also check out
macro factor that is the diet app that
Greg and I co-developed along with an
extremely talented team of colleagues
it's a really fantastic nutrition app
and it does come with a free trial so
you can try it out see if you like it
before you actually pay for the product
now let's get into some of this
nutrition content like I said I'm going
to be going through some really popular
diets and some popular myths in the
nutrition world and I'm going to be
discussing them in the most unbiased way
I can and what I mean by that is this
isn't going to be one of those uh
podcasts where I just debunk things and
uh you know kind of rant about things in
a vitriolic manner I want to talk about
these diets and say okay I don't like
this diet but here are some of the pros
of this diet some of the advantages
here are the cons and here's why the
cons outweigh the pros when it comes to
myths and misconceptions I want to talk
about any little granules of truth that
might be underneath the surface and I
want to talk about why those myths are
so compelling why they seem to be so uh
so convincing so uh it's gonna I'm gonna
try to thread that needle where I I will
discuss some things that I I think are
uh you know generally misguided but I'm
gonna try to be fair about it and say
what the pros and cons are for each
thing now before we get into those
popular diets I do want to provide a
very brief refresher so a few episodes
ago I talked a little bit about how we
even begin to describe a healthy diet or
or more appropriately a healthy eating
pattern you know I don't like to rely
too much on naming this diet versus that
diet I like to talk more broadly about
what eating patterns seem to be
compatible with good health and good
performance and so in that episode I
talked about two sets of criteria
there's the healthy diet indicator
criteria from 2015 and then an updated
set of healthy diet indicator criteria
from 2020 and I want to briefly list
what some of these criteria are and
again these are things that would
generally describe a dietary pattern
that is compatible with supporting good
health so first of all eating plenty of
fruits and vegetables keeping total fat
to less than 30 percent of total energy
keeping saturated fat to less than 10
percent of total energy
keeping polyunsaturated fats between 6
and 11 percent of total energy keeping
free sugars and kind of added sugars you
could say to less than 10 percent of
total energy trying to get at least 25
grams of fiber a day and trying to get
at least 3.5 grams of sodium per day now
some of those you know they're not
always going to be perfect in every
single context right there you can
absolutely have a suitable diet for you
that has more than 30 percent of
calories coming from fat but those are
the healthy diet indicator criteria that
kind of start as our starting point you
know they serve as our starting point
for identifying Health uh Health
supporting dietary patterns now those
were updated in 2020 and there were a
couple additions or changes to to point
out uh in the in 2020 in that version
they mentioned specifically try to get
more beans and legumes into the diet try
to get nuts and seeds into the diet try
to get some whole grains into the diet
diet try to limit dietary sodium to less
than two grams a day try to minimize the
intake of processed meat and try to
consume unprocessed red meat in
moderation so it's not to say you can't
have any red meat but red meat in
moderation again there are certain
contexts where some of these criteria
are less less relevant or less suitable
so sodium is one that comes to mind
if you're someone whose blood pressure
is in the normal range you do a ton of
exercise in a hot environment you're
sweating like crazy on a regular basis
you probably will thrive on a diet where
sodium does exceed two grams a day so I
don't want to suggest that these
criteria are always perfect for all
individuals but I do think they offer a
decent starting point for what we are
looking for in a healthy dietary pattern
and the reason I do this refresher is as
we go through some of these popular
diets you're going to be able to keep
those in the back of your mind and say
okay this diet seems like it's really
pushing us away from several of those
criteria which would lead us to believe
this diet probably not the best diet for
a large percentage of individuals
so let's dive in here first I want to
talk about low carb diets and of course
this is a very broad category it would
include other diets within it so the
Zone diet is a popular diet that you
could call a low carb approach the South
Beach Diet is a popular diet that you
could call a low carb approach the South
Beach Diet I haven't heard much about it
in a while but you know several years
ago it was quite popular so
when we talk about low-carb diets we're
usually talking about a diet where
carbohydrate is making up less than 35
or less than 40 percent of total energy
so
um you know a lot of times if you look
at common dietary recommendations they
might say to have 45 to 65 percent of
your calories coming from carbohydrate
low carb diets could broadly refer to
basically anything below that sometimes
it gets really low and you'll see car
carb intakes that are well below 35
percent of total energy but we're
starting very broad here and talking
about low carb diets in the most General
sense possible now there are Pros
Associated or benefits or advantages
that you could associate with low carb
diet approaches uh personally I think
that low carb diets are a very sensible
way to reduce calories especially for
people who are not doing a lot of
exercise
um people who are are doing a ton of
high intensity exercise probably are not
going to thrive on a low carb diet they
probably need to make sure they're
fueling their exercise appropriately but
for for most folks who are not doing a
ton of high intensity exercise a low
carb diet is a very sensible approach a
very suitable approach for their needs
so if you're going to be removing
calories from the diet carbohydrate is
one place where you could remove a
pretty substantial portion of calories
from the diet and and as long as you're
not doing a ton of high intensity
exercise probably not going to have
massive downsides within reason
and another Advantage here
with low carb diets is most of the time
you're going to see people doing low
carbs in conjunction with high protein
and when people do this low carb high
protein approach they're usually quite
satisfied with their diet even when
calories are relatively low and those
types of diets do a pretty good job of
keeping hunger at Bay so like I said for
a lot of people a low carb approach can
be a very suitable way to initiate a
lower calorie diet if they're pursuing a
fat loss goal for example when it comes
to the downsides of low carb approaches
there was a recent meta-analysis that
linked uh you know pretty excessive carb
restriction to lower testosterone levels
particularly when energy intake was low
and protein intake was very high
that is a thing that is observed in the
literature but I'm not overly concerned
about that personally
I'm not really a big fan kind of
micromanaging testosterone levels if
you're just kind of interested in losing
some fat and you lower your cap your
your calories and your carbohydrate a
little bit I don't expect a meaningful
impact on testosterone levels but the
more pertinent downside of carb
restriction like I mentioned is if
you're doing a bunch of glycolytic
activity if you're doing high intensity
exercise or very high volumes of even
moderate intensity exercise you might
find yourself in a situation where you
are under fueling the physical activity
that you're doing and there could be
some unfavorable consequences associated
with that
now when it comes to popular
applications and some common
misconceptions like I said the Zone diet
is a type of low carb diet which does
tend to be relatively high in protein as
well the downside with the Zone diet uh
it's fine it's you know there's nothing
about the Zone diet that jumps off the
page as being totally dangerous or
deleterious or anything like that but
overall it just has some rules and
restrictions and guidelines that are a
little bit more restrictive than
necessary there are some sacrifices
required to adhere to the diet that
really aren't giving a lot of of payout
you know you you are making these
sacrifices and you're not really getting
much from making them so whenever we
look at a dietary pattern that requires
major sacrifices that have
disproportionately low payoff I usually
avoid those dietary approaches because
we're making these massive sacrifices
that can meaning thankfully impact
flexibility sustainability quality of
life and we're just not getting much for
it okay so the Zone diet like I said
overall not the worst diet in the world
but there are some rules and guidelines
that if you're trying to follow them to
a t uh it just makes the diet a little
bit harder than it needs to be
so if you were someone who is saying
yeah I like the general macronutrient
breakdown of the Zone diet I like the
general recommendation for meal
frequency but I'm not going to beat
myself up about the details I actually
think it ends up being a fairly sensible
approach now the South Beach Diet is
another low carb diet plan and it tends
to work in phases and the reason I bring
that up is I would not advocate for the
South Beach Diet personally the first
phase is a bit too extreme for my liking
I've seen some claims that you know if
you do phase one over the first two
weeks you can expect to lose like eight
to 13 pounds that's way more restrictive
than I would Advocate and just like I
mentioned previously with the South
Beach Diet there are a number of
guidelines associated with the diet that
are just way more restrictive than I
would consider necessary so I think you
can do a really great low carb diet
without locking yourself into the zone
diet or the South Beach Diet or anything
that is so formal with so many different
guidelines and restrictions
when it comes to misconceptions in the
low carb diet World
there are a couple to highlight one is
that a lot of folks who Advocate on
behalf of low carb diets
they tend to get really hung up on
glycemic index values now 10 years ago
this was very prevalent nowadays people
are moving away from it for good reason
the glycemic index is a very flawed
metric I've mentioned it on the podcast
before but basically with the glycemic
index they are looking at
the immediate like
usually they're looking over a two hour
period but they're looking at the
immediate blood glucose response to
ingestion of a given serving of that
food so usually it they'll they'll
standardize if they're going to try to
test the glycemic index value for
carrots for example they would provide a
serving that would yield usually about
50 grams of available
carbohydrate you know you'd eat however
many carrots you have to eat to get to
that 50 gram kind of standardized dose
and then they would look at the area
under the curve of that glucose response
they would basically look at the the
blood glucose Excursion you know the way
that blood glucose goes up and down
after the ingestion of that food and so
what they would do is they would take
the area under curve of that of that
blood glucose response uh multiply it
and end up getting this glycemic index
value
um so what they were trying to do with
this uh or what ends up happening with
glycemic index values
is you are necessarily penalizing foods
that cause a quicker blood glucose
response you know when you're kind of
refining the time window to that
immediate phase you're just kind of
looking at what foods are immediately
going to cause a blood glucose response
and how large is that blood glucose
response so sometimes you do find foods
that have surprisingly high glycemic
index values but but they're foods that
you would never associate with you know
increasing one's predisposition to
diabetes or anything like that so the
shortcomings of the glycemic index are
multi-faceted first of all it's measured
with a set number of net carbs but that
ignores uh you know the serving size
that a person would typically eat
um you know so instead of saying hey how
many pretzels would you eat in a serving
versus carrots instead of kind of baking
that into the metric they standardize
glycemic index to have a certain amount
of of net carbohydrate in a way that
kind of removes the relevance of this
value from the way the food is typically
consumed another another thing along
those lines the relevance of glycemic
index is really
um really diminished when you consider
the fact that usually glycemic index is
going to be measured when you're eating
a single food after an overnight fast so
instead of consuming a food within a
more typical dietary pattern maybe it's
a food that you normally have for lunch
and you typically have it with one or
two other foods that go with it we're
kind of removing the food from its
context we're removing the food from the
typical serving size and so we're really
losing a lot of diet specific relevance
when we look at a glycemic index value
and then another shortcoming is that the
glycemic index really just doesn't tell
you much about the overall quality of
the food you're not you're not
understanding what kind of
micronutrients are associated with the
food
um you know there are a lot of
shortcomings there as well so if I'm
looking at evaluating a carbohydrate
source and trying to determine is this a
really valuable carbohydrate Source or
perhaps a less valuable kind of
extraneous carbohydrate Source in my
diet I'm going to look at a number of
things but I'm not going to look at the
glycemic index I'm going to look at the
vitamin and mineral mineral content I'm
going to look at the fiber content the
energy density uh how well I tolerate it
in terms of gastrointestinal Comfort
palatability just whether or not I enjoy
the food the convenience of the food in
terms of cooking it storing it things
like that and even the cost of the food
you know there are a number of practical
things that we should consider when
we're determining what type of
carbohydrate Foods we want to include in
our diet and ultimately because of all
those shortcomings I listed glycemic
index really should not be high on the
list and in many cases really shouldn't
be on the list at all there is one
caveat
um you know some people will say I don't
use glycemic index but I do use glycemic
load because glycemic load actually
accounts for the typical serving size of
a food that is consumed rather than
standardizing to a particular number of
net carbs so the glycemic load is an
improvement compared to glycemic index
but it still does share a number of the
shortcomings that I mentioned previously
so that's one caveat I want to mention a
second caveat is you know it's very
possible
that you have uh some type of challenge
related to glycemic control so perhaps
you have insulin resistance maybe you
have a particular form of diabetes it's
very possible that you are working with
a medical professional to manage your
blood glucose responses to individual
meals if that is the case you should
absolutely trust the advice that you're
getting from a medical professional not
me some dude talking on a podcast okay
so if you're managing a medical
condition that is uh that pertains to
glycemic control there might be some
instances where you do want to use
glycemic load or glycemic index you want
to work with a medical professional to
figure out how you should be managing
your blood glucose excursions after
eating a particular food or a particular
meal
now along these lines when we talk about
blood glucose excursions back in the day
people would just say what's the
glycemic index value you know if that
value is high I'm going to avoid it if
the value is low that's all good more
recently people who Embrace low carb
diets are getting into the use of
continuous glucose monitors and these
are medical devices that monitor your
blood glucose levels on a continuous
basis as you probably figured out from
from the name uh I am not really on
board with widespread use
of these continuous glucose monitors
within the fitness world and there are
multiple reasons for that first of all
looking through the data that are
currently available looking through the
research I'm really not impressed about
the or I'm not impressed by the validity
and the reliability data for these
devices whether we're talking about
day-to-day uh comparisons person to
person comparisons or device to device
comparisons I'm not seeing a level of
consistency reliability validity that I
would hope for if I were going to
implement this type of device in a
meaningful way I know for a lot of folks
who are managing you know diabetes
insulin resistance you know these
devices can be very helpful it's kind of
the best available thing in certain
contexts I definitely understand that
I'm not a medical professional I I'm not
someone who would be advising someone on
how to use a continuous glucose monitor
in order to manage a a glycemic control
issue or you know a diabetes diagnosis
or anything like that but in terms of
people who are trying to really
micromanage these glucose excursions
that are within the normal range I just
don't think these devices have the
validity and reliability that we would
want in order to really put that into
action another issue that I have with
these devices
it's not really an issue with the
devices but an issue with the way
they're being applied and with the way
that their data are being interpreted
within the Fitness World some people are
adopting interpret interpretations
of the uh the glucose Excursion data
that they're getting from these devices
and they're they're interpreting the
information in a way that inevitably is
leading them toward ketogenic diets um
like in a hundred percent of cases so
basically what they're doing is they are
starting out and just kind of looking at
okay how does my blood glucose respond
to this meal versus that meal and what
they're finding is you know okay I'm
getting lower uh you know excursions
smaller excursions lower uh Peak glucose
responses when I'm airing toward these
meals that are higher in fat and lower
in carbohydrate so people are finding
over time that they're just kind of
drifting toward a ketogenic diet if
they're letting the continuous glucose
monitor call the shots and it's not
because they're experiencing any
unfavorable effects from these normal
blood glucose excursions they're just
trying to basically go for the lowest
score possible
um which is not something that I think
is really rooted in any sound uh health
related data you know there's no reason
to believe that going lower than a
normal glucose Excursion is going to
have meaningful health benefits for an
otherwise healthy individual so we're
seeing that people are just kind of
going for the lowest score possible and
now they're drifting toward meals that
are more compatible with a ketogenic
diet they're drifting toward a ketogenic
diet in general because of that
meal-to-meal fluctuation in the way that
they're managing their food choices and
then what they're finding
is that they're adhering to a ketogenic
diet for an extended period of time and
after you've been doing that for a while
uh your body responds to the way you eat
um and so if you've been on a ketogenic
diet for a while a lot of the enzymatic
Machinery that helps you clear blood
glucose after a high carbohydrate meal a
lot of that enzymatic Machinery is
temporarily lost you can get it back by
adopting you know moving back to a more
moderate macronutrient distribution but
what people are finding is that once
they're you know the continuous glucose
monitor data is kind of nudging them
toward a ketogenic diet and then once
they're on that ketogenic diet for a
while if they do have a high carb meal
uh you know the blood glucose response
is just off the charts and that's
because they've been on a ketogenic diet
for so long so it creates this kind of
self-reinforcing mechanism where you are
nudged toward a ketogenic diet and then
you are very strongly encouraged to stay
on that ketogenic diet and so for a lot
of folks who who ask me like hey I'm
thinking about using a continuous
glucose monitor uh you know I'm gonna
kind of let it dictate how I eat I
usually tell people like hey if that's
what you want to do just kind of just
like cut straight to the punch line you
know just go to the finish here and go
right to the part where you're just on a
ketogenic diet because if you do follow
that process more likely than not it's
just going to tell you hey you know if
you're on a ketogenic diet you're not
going to have these normal blood glucose
excursions so uh yeah like I said most
people who are who reach out to me and
express interest I just say hey I can
tell you where this ends it's probably
going to end with you being on a diet
that is either ketogenic or very close
to ketogenic so if you want to do that
just go straight to straight to it you
know you don't have to kind of go
through this process of letting the
device kind of slowly push you there so
moving on we've talked a little little
bit about low carb diets in general like
I said
very sensible if you're taking a very
moderate approach and you're doing it
with a lot of flexibility in terms of
your food choices there are some less
flexible applications that I would not
advise and there are also some myths
associated with low carb diets that you
want to be wary of you want to keep an
eye out for them now moving on
gluten-free diet this is going to be
pretty quick because it got really
popular a few years back and I think the
popularity is waning a bit in terms of
the pros of adopting a gluten-free diet
on the bright side if you reduce the
gluten content of your diet from a
nutritional perspective you're probably
not missing out on much you're going to
be you know if you're omitting foods
with a lot of gluten it's very unlikely
that you're going to be missing out on
really really important critical
micronutrients that you couldn't get
elsewhere and you can still achieve a
really broad range of macronutrient
distribution even if you cut gluten out
of your diet now you might notice that
your carb intake goes down but there are
gluten-free carb sources that you could
you know you you could certainly be on a
high carb diet that that doesn't contain
gluten
um when it comes to oh and I should also
mention another positive element some
people
when they adopt a gluten-free diet
they start to cut out a lot of high carb
foods they start to cut out a lot of
foods with high energy density and they
also start to cut out a lot of processed
foods with high energy density a lot of
foods that are very snackable and so a
lot of folks when they do a gluten-free
diet they notice that they start to lose
some weight and their calorie intake
goes down without really intentionally
trying to lose weight or cut calories
and so that could be an unintended
benefit depending on what your goals are
and what's interesting about that is it
reinforces an idea unfortunately kind of
reinforces a myth that gluten-free diets
cause weight loss because gluten is bad
you know basically it creates a scenario
where people say man that gluten must
have been terrible for me because once I
cut it out I started losing weight I
started feeling great Etc in reality a
lot of that weight loss that that is
observed when people adopted gluten-free
diet just because they're cutting out
some of these energy dense foods that
they typically snack on now some of the
Cons with a gluten-free diet I mentioned
that nutritionally you're not missing
out on much when you cut out gluten but
in terms of just having flexibility with
your food choices you are missing out
there are a lot of really popular foods
that people love to eat in many regions
of the world that that do contain a
great deal of gluten so a lot of folks
when they adopt a gluten-free diet they
notice that a lot of their favorite
foods are now off the menu so you might
not be missing much nutritionally but
you might be missing a lot in terms of
just having a flexible diet that you
really enjoy
um
and another con I should mention here is
people often are just making a making a
restriction that isn't necessary you
know there are a lot of folks who adopt
a gluten-free diet expecting that you
know simply by removing gluten from
their diet they're going to cause a
bunch of really positive health effects
in many cases they will not experience
any direct benefit from avoiding gluten
so whether you view that as a downside
is kind of a matter of perspective but a
lot of folks are making a sacrifice that
ultimately is not producing the outcome
that they were hoping for uh now things
I want to address when it comes to
gluten-free diets if you have celiac
disease absolutely you want to avoid
gluten and of course you want to work
with medical professionals to figure out
how to put together a diet that is going
to be most suitable for your medical
condition uh
for a while there there were a lot of
folks talking about something called
non-celiac gluten sensitivity
this got really popular there was some
initial research indicating that you
know there were these people who did not
have celiac disease they also were not
allergic to wheat but there were there
were some very small initial studies
indicating that these individuals were
noticing a lot of positive changes when
they cut gluten out of their diet
specifically they were noticing a
reduction of unfavorable
gastrointestinal symptoms when they cut
gluten out of their diet so there seemed
to be this group of folks this
percentage of the population who wasn't
allergic to wheat and did not have
celiac disease but nonetheless it
appeared that gluten was causing some
gastrointestinal distress for them and
if they remove gluten from their diet
you know of course that would cease
those symptoms would stop
more recent research kind of uh you know
that people continued down that line of
research more recent evidence has
suggested that what was initially called
gluten sensitivity might be more broadly
characterized as a sensitivity to
fodmaps and so these are undigestible or
partially digestible carbohydrates that
um you know basically what they found in
some of these follow-up studies is they
thought that removing gluten
was causing these gastrointestinal
symptoms to dissipate when in reality it
was the removal of fodmaps that were
present in some of these gluten
containing foods and so the last I
checked in on this literature it's been
a while since I dug back into the
literature but last I checked there
seemed to be a a growing consensus that
non-celiac gluten sensitivity was most
commonly actually a FODMAP sensitivity
and so in that case you might find that
a gluten-free diet does uh e it caused
some of those symptoms to reduce in
frequency or severity some of those
gastrointestinal symptoms
um but in many cases it seems that
what's really happening is it's not
reducing gluten that is causing the
effect it's actually just reducing
fodmaps in the diet now that gets really
tricky uh because
fodmaps are kind of everywhere if you
just Google low FODMAP diet and you get
an idea of what foods you're supposed to
avoid on a low FODMAP diet you will
quickly find that it is a very very
restrictive diet and so usually what
people do is if they notice that they
have a FODMAP sensitivity of some type
is they will start out with a low FODMAP
diet kind of an Elimination Diet I'm
saying hey I'm sick of these
gastrointestinal symptoms sick of
feeling like crap I'm going to do a low
FODMAP diet first
and then what they do is they gradually
reintroduce some of these FODMAP
containing foods uh one or two at a time
that kind of slowly do this gradual
process of reintroduction and they
figure out which foods seem to cause
symptoms and which foods do not uh and
so when people look at a low FODMAP diet
their first uh their first impression is
this sucks like I I don't know if I can
sustain a low FODMAP diet for for months
or years on end and fortunately that is
not the typical use case in most cases a
low FODMAP diet is initially adopted as
an Elimination Diet and then FODMAP
containing food sources are introduced
very systematically so that a person can
identify which foods seem to cause
issues for them and you know I've never
considered myself someone who has a
broadly speaking a FODMAP sensitivity
but there are some foods that do contain
fodmaps like very specific food sources
that when I eat them I seem to just have
some minor stomach discomfort so there's
nothing at all wrong with you know
really mindfully revisiting your food
intakes and figuring out what foods seem
to really sit well for you and what
foods don't there's nothing wrong with
that so when someone tells me they're on
a gluten-free diet I don't immediately
dismiss that and say oh you got swept up
in a fad diet you have no idea what
you're doing I feel bad for you because
you're you've been LED so far astray
that that's genuinely not my first
reaction my first reaction is hey good
for them they started to really uh take
a proactive approach to their nutrition
they started to make some observations
about what foods work for them what
foods don't and they tailor their diet
accordingly so I I really
um
I think it's really unfortunate that you
know gluten-free diets became a bit of a
fad diet some people started adopting
them uh really without a good
justification for adopting them and for
a lot of folks who respond quite well to
gluten-free diets or you know removal of
certain fodmaps from their diet
unfortunately it puts them in a position
where it looks like they're you know
just jumping on the bandwagon of some
fad diet in reality it's really
important to take note of how different
foods seem to impact you and of course
you should always alter your diet in a
way that is suitable for making you feel
your best and and helping you be your
healthiest so I did mention in that
section things like celiac disease and
certain food sensitivities once again if
you believe you're experiencing any kind
of medical symptoms or clinical symptoms
your first move should be to get with a
medical professional so you can talk
through that and rule out serious
medical conditions and then you can work
with them to figure out how you might
consider are adjusting your diet in a
way that's appropriate for you and your
medical circumstances
now moving on I want to just broadly
address the concept of eating clean
so eating clean or consuming only clean
Foods
it's kind of a vague term broadly
speaking it involves consuming what we
might call Whole Foods that are
minimally processed and generally
speaking talking about foods that are
typically embraced by bodybuilder types
people who who kind of self-identify as
health nuts so like you know you're
going to see a lot of folks who who say
that they eat clean you're going to see
them avoid gluten avoid certain grain
products or dairy products sometimes
they're usually going to be the folks
who say like hey broccoli chicken breast
lean proteins you know starchy
carbohydrate sources with low glycemic
index values you know you can kind of
start to see how eating clean wraps you
know some of the things we've talked
about previously get folded into it
there's a lot of folks who claim that
they eat clean and they avoid avoid some
of these you know they they might adopt
a gluten-free diet or a very low gluten
diet they might notice that their carb
intake is going down that they're doing
more uh they're embracing more low
glycemic index carbohydrates so some of
these topics are highly interrelated and
correlated
um but a lot of times you know the
simple heuristic for someone who says
that they eat clean is just ask yourself
if I were to go to a bodybuilding
Magazine from 2005 and open it up to a
page that says hey here's a sample diet
what am I going to see in there it's
going to be brown rice it's going to be
sweet potatoes it's going to be chicken
breast it's going to be lean beef it's
going to be broccoli you know fibrous
vegetables it's all of those
bodybuilding staple foods that we've be
that we have generally become accustomed
to in the Fitness World so eat and clean
very very popular especially among
physique athletes and in the physique
athlete and bodybuilding World there is
a bit of a a Divergence there's been
kind of two camps that form there's the
people who eat clean and have you know
some of these more rigid approaches to
which foods are considered good or
permissible and which foods are
considered bad or not permissible uh you
know so if you're eating clean you
probably have a list of foods that are
acceptable and everything else is off
the menu and there's this whole other
Camp of physique athletes and
bodybuilders who say well I'll eat any
food sources out there as long as it's
fitting my macro targets for the day so
this very flexible approach to Food
Source selection there's these kind of
two camps that that formed now I don't
want to make it seem like I'm you know
totally against the concept of eating
clean I mean if you're on a diet where
you know if you're on some kind of like
clean Foods diet as some might say
there are some some advantages there
right so you're eating plenty of foods
that are very nutrient dense
and it is uh a dieting framework where
you have some flexibility with your
macronutrient distribution so eating
clean does not lock you into a
particular macronutrient distribution a
lot of folks who eat clean will notice
that their carb intake in many cases
tends to go down a little bit just
because they're
um they're less likely to embrace a lot
of processed carbohydrate food sources
but generally speaking like hey there's
there's plenty of good foods in there
plenty of foods that provide a lot of
micronutrients a lot of fiber getting
plenty of protein there's a lot to like
when you look at the types of foods that
are included in what we would call a
clean eating dietary pattern however
there are some shortcomings
obviously there's going to be limited
variety
um and what's interesting about that is
these Foods on an individual basis if
you're eating clean on an individual
basis they tend to have plenty of
micronutrients but because you are
limiting the variety of your food
sources you are limiting the breadth of
your macro or your micronutrient
coverage right so you might be eating
foods that have a ton of vitamin C and a
ton of vitamin A but that you know you
could eat three times your daily need
for Vitamin C but that's not really
helping you get vitamin D or vitamin E
into your diet so you can see how you
could be eating plenty of foods that are
nutrient dense but if they all can say
if they all contain the same
micronutrients you might actually have
some micronutrient gaps in your diet
which a lot of people would never expect
you say what do you eat you say oh my
God every food I eat is like super clean
tons of vitamins and minerals but if
they're all containing the same vitamins
and minerals you might actually have
glaring gaps in your diet and there was
a study by Ishmael and colleagues in
2017 indicating that in some cases
people who eat clean they actually do
find when they analyze their their food
logs hey you actually have some some
gaps here that might be filled if you
had a more flexible approach to your
food source selection and there's even a
study by conlon and colleagues Lauren
conlon who works in the fitness industry
she's excellent she published a study
with a bunch of colleagues in 2021 where
they found similar or even arguably
slightly better body composition
outcomes when people were using flexible
dieting rather than a kind of rigid
clean eating dietary approach so when we
look at micronutrient coverage and when
we just look at bigger picture outcomes
in terms of dietary success
there are some potential shortcomings
with locking yourself into a rigid diet
plan that only Embraces some of these
foods that are called clean Foods
along those lines you know the biggest
shortcoming here
with clean eating is the rigidity the
lack of flexibility in some cases it's
not going to be very practical it's not
going to be very sustainable uh you know
you can do it for four weeks at a time
when you have no social events and no
trips or vacations but you'll probably
run into a situation where you get to a
restaurant for a birthday party and you
say when the world am I going to eat
here you know another thing is that it
tends to reinforce what we call rigid
cognitive restraint and the reason I say
that is because we have to dichotomize
Foods as being either good or bad
they're either allowed or not allowed
and when we look at the ramifications of
rigid cognitive restraint when it comes
to dieting we often see that rigid
restraint is associated with unfavorable
psychological outcomes and really isn't
all that good for dietary success in the
first place when it just comes to Simply
attaining the goals that you set out for
yourself and there was a great review
paper uh by Eric Helms and colleagues in
2019 that talks a lot about rigid
cognitive restraint versus flexible
cognitive restraint and talks about
frankly the shortcomings of adopting
rigid cognitive restraints so clean
eating uh there are plenty of you know
really high quality food sources that
come with it but there are a number of
disadvantages there
now earlier we talked about low carb
diets and I did briefly mention
ketogenic diets so I do want to talk
very specifically about ketogenic diets
and with a ketogenic diet typically
you're looking at a diet where less than
10 percent of your car less than 10
percent of your calories are coming from
carbohydrates so this is a very very low
carbohydrate diet approach
um broadly speaking there's going to be
a lot of fat in the diet sometimes up to
70 or 80 percent of calories coming from
fat and then there's going to be you
know enough protein in there to get the
job done basically so very low carb much
higher in fat than the typical diet and
enough protein to meet the individual's
goals in terms of supporting muscle mass
and strength now 10 percent of carbs is
a common definition or a common limit I
should say for ketogenic diets but some
people rather than focusing on total
carbs they will look at net carbs
instead so they'll basically remove
fiber from the equation and only count
their non-fiber carbohydrates and
they'll set some type of of goal for the
day or some type of limit in terms of
grams of net carbohydrate per day and I
think the reason people do that
is if you're on a relatively low calorie
diet and you're saying that you know
less than 10 percent of your total
calories can can come from carbohydrate
um one of the issues there is it can be
very difficult to meet even the most
bare minimum guidelines for vegetable
intake so I think a lot of folks say
okay I'm going to incorporate some
fibrous vegetables into my diet try to
minimize the starchy vegetables and see
if I can get to a carb intake using this
net carb approach that is low enough to
be compatible with a ketogenic diet but
also allows me to kind of check some of
these boxes in terms of vegetable intake
because like I said going all the way
back to some of those healthy diet
indicator criteria
um you know getting plenty of vegetables
in the diet broadly speaking is is
considered a tremendously healthy thing
to do there are very few people who push
back against that and the more
importantly the literature sure bears
that out you really don't want to be on
a diet where you are aggressively
restricting high fiber vegetables so
like I said people on keto sometimes
they just limit their total carbs to to
less than 10 percent of their total
energy intake sometimes they focus on
net carbs instead now ketogenic diets
used to be viewed in the fitness world
as a pretty extreme diet
um you know it they it used to be viewed
as largely reserved for people who had
some very specific medical conditions
related to carbohydrate metabolism in
the brain so if you look at a lot of the
literotron ketogenic diets one of the
key applications
is for some seizure disorders where
people have inborn errors uh in terms of
carbohydrate metabolism in their brain
they were born with these medical
conditions where the brain is not able
to process carbohydrate as effectively
as as we would like and as a result due
to that inborn error in carbohydrate
metabolism in the brain seizures are
experienced so there are a lot of people
for whom a ketogenic diet is a
life-saving uh you know just in terms of
quality of life uh just a life-changing
medical intervention there are people
who have really remarkable uh
Improvement in seizure related
conditions from adopting a ketogenic
diet so in terms of ketogenic diets as a
medical intervention for specific
medical conditions there is so much good
that has been done by ketogenic diets
now the question is you know how does
that pertain to the the you know the
typical Fitness population who does not
have a medical condition that would that
would normally be treated by a ketogenic
diet so uh you know like I said back in
the day several years ago ketogenic
diets were considered pretty extreme in
the Fitness World it was considered kind
of a specific medical intervention for
seizure disorders and some other medical
conditions but when it comes to the
Fitness World the uh the Overton window
has really shifted when it comes to what
diets are considered extreme so nowadays
a ketogenic diet is considered is
considered pretty mainstream because
more extreme diets have really moved
into the space on a larger scale so when
we look at a ketogenic diet versus a
more traditional macronutrient breakdown
a ketogenic diet
tends to be similar or in some cases
slightly better for fat loss now if
we're controlling calories a ketogenic
diet is unlikely to be better for fat
loss but when keto where we see
ketogenic diets excel in the fat loss
literature it largely has to do with
appetite reduction so if we take two
people and we just say hey try to lose
some weight one group you know one
person is doing a ketogenic diet the
other is not the person on the ketogenic
diet these ketogenic diets tend to have
a pretty robust effect in in terms of
suppressing appetite so a person on a
ketogenic ketogenic diet might find it
to be a little bit easier to adhere to a
lower calorie diet
largely because they're keeping hunger
at Bay now they might find it harder to
adhere because a ketogenic diet is going
to be more restrictive and there's going
to be less flexibility in terms of what
foods they're able to increase
incorporate so there are pros and cons
there for fat loss a ketogenic diet may
be better
because it can reduce appetite for some
individuals it may be worse because they
say I'm trying to do this ketogenic diet
but I love carbohydrate foods and so I'm
just really struggling with adherence
and therefore I'm not able to really
effectively reduce my calorie intake so
there are some situations where keto can
be favorable for fat loss somewhere it
can be unfavorable and a large number of
scenarios where both both approaches are
actually going to be very equivalent in
terms of inducing fat loss now when it
comes to lean body mass or muscle mass
Studies have indicated that ketogenic
diets are actually slightly worse than a
more traditional macronutrient breakdown
now people who Advocate on behalf of
ketogenic diets often argue that this is
just due to water weight so when you go
on a very low carb diet your muscles and
your liver store less glycogen glycogen
stores water with it and so as you're
losing glycogen in terms of of total
storage you lose some water weight as
well so a lot of folks will argue that
when we look at the research showing
drops in fat-free mass or muscle mass or
lean body mass a lot of people will
argue we're just seeing a reduction of
water weight
that can be attributed to the loss of
glycogen that certainly could be a
contributing factor I'm not fully
convinced that it is the only Factor
dictating some of these outcomes
pertaining to fat-free mass or muscle
mass there could be other factors at
play for example if you are doing a lot
of glycolytic resistance training if
you're doing you know more high volume
High repetition uh short rest period if
that is what your your workouts are
looking like it is possible that a
ketogenic diet could impair your
performance to some extent and could
have Downstream effects on your ability
to gain or maintain muscle mass now it's
really important to recognize the
details of your training are going to
dictate whether or not a ketogenic diet
is going to impact your performance or
your ability to maintain muscle like I
said high volume High repetition short
rest periods that 10 to be pretty
glycolytic it's very possible that a
ketogenic diet could lead to an
impairment in your performance if you're
doing CrossFit type training or circuit
training it's even more likely that a
ketogenic diet could start to impact
your performance in an unfavorable way
which could threaten your ability to
maintain muscle now if you're doing a
weight lifting or power lifting style
training most of your training might be
sets of one or three or five repetitions
and you might take five seven ten
minutes between sets and you might be on
a program that overall has pretty low
training volume
within those circumstances to be honest
I would not expect a ketogenic diet to
impair performance much at all and in
fact it could could very well be
equivalent so I I've talked to a lot of
folks over the years who say Eric you
know I I keep hearing that ketogenic
diets are bad for resistance training
performance but you know I I'm on a low
volume power lifting program most of my
training I'm just doing heavy sets of
three and I feel fine and that really
doesn't surprise me at all you know so
if you're on that type of program you
can probably do a ketogenic diet without
impacting your performance really at all
but the more glycolytic your training
gets the more likely it is that a
ketogenic diet could lead to a
performance impairment and if you're
performing more poorly over time you
could theoretically expect a reduction
in muscle mass or just you're you're
leaving potential gains on the table in
terms of gaining new muscle mass so
that's a very contentious topic and like
I said I'm I'm being very transparent
there's a lot of nuance when it comes to
looking at a individual scenario the way
that person trains and trying to figure
out if a ketogenic diet might impair
their performance
there are some applications where a
ketogenic diet should be able to
facilitate resistance training
performance and there are some
applications where it probably won't
while we're on the topic of ketogenic
diets and popular diets
one that I want to mention is the Atkins
diet and this kind of falls under the
umbrella of ketogenic diets because my
understanding is that the Atkins diet as
it was originally developed was a diet
that occurs in phases I believe there
were four phases in total the first
phase is very reminiscent of just a
typical ketogenic diet and then my
understanding is that from there phase
two three and four involve an
incremental reintroduction of some
carbohydrate so it basically as you
progress through the four phases of the
Atkins diet as it was originally created
you you kind of go from a ketogenic diet
and work your way up to a more typical
low-carb diet by the time you get to
phase four so I did want to just mention
the Atkins diet because people ask about
it a lot my feelings about the Atkins
diet are basically all the things I just
described about ketogenic diets and then
low carb diets as well so I'm not
um you know I wouldn't say that the
Atkins diet approach is terrible for all
people in all cases but it is a very
restrictive approach it's important to
acknowledge that
um and you know for some people the low
carbs are really not going to impact any
outcome that is uh really important to
them you know some people can do a
ketogenic diet or an Atkins diet and it
can support their performance goals
their health related goals Etc but for
some individuals they will find that you
know for example they were doing a lot
of high intensity activity they tried
the Atkins diet and their performance
tank and they realize hey this is not
for me
one final thing I should mention about
ketogenic diets Atkins diets low carb
diets
I want to Circle back to the healthy
diet indicator criteria
two of the criteria were having total
fat below 30 percent of total energy
having saturated fat below 10 total
energy
a lot of folks on ketogenic diets and
the Atkins diet are are not going to
adhere to those
um to those criteria right and like I
said the healthy diet indicator criteria
they are a good broad set of guidelines
that are compatible with the best
available nutritional science but some
folks will say you know what
I'm not really worried about optimizing
my blood lipids I'm not really worried
about optimizing my cardio metabolic
Health outcomes uh you know I'm not I'm
not building my diet based on my
concerns about cardiovascular disease
risk in three decades so I you know when
we talk about how these diets are going
to be incorporated I don't want to give
the illusion as I try to point out some
of their positive attributes that these
diets will all Impact long-term Health
in the same exact way ultimately like I
said I think if you want to really hedge
your bets and set yourself up for the
best possible long-term Health
ramifications I do think you want to
adhere to as many of those healthy diet
indicator criteria as you feasibly can
while still maintaining a sustainable
dietary pattern so when you start to
look at ketogenic diets Atkins diet
things like that you will come to find
that there are elements that do
disregard some of these guidelines lines
that are considered best practice for
minimizing long-term risk of
cardiovascular events and it's important
to highlight that is a shortcoming in my
opinion now there are people who
will argue and argue and argue and argue
that we know virtually nothing at all
about LDL cholesterol and how different
blood lipid parameters pertain to to
long-term cardiovascular outcomes that's
not an argument that I enjoy
participating in I do refer people to a
really nice three-part article series
over at Sigma nutrition by Alan Flanagan
that talks through all the evidence
pertaining to saturated fat dietary fat
blood lipids heart disease you know it
really is a comprehensive three-part
Series so I'll do my best to remember
linking that in the show notes but but
it is something to keep in mind as
you're considering things like a
ketogenic diet or an Atkins diet
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
alright moving on the next diet I want
to talk about is the paleo diet and the
paleo diet is the you know the general
premise is that over the course of our
evolutionary history as a species Homo
sapiens ate a certain selection of foods
and theoretically we would be better
served by eating the foods that we ate
during our evolutionary process or in
other words eating the foods that we
were theoretically evolved to eat so
that's the premise and in order to
identify what those foods are Advocates
of the paleo diet say let's go back to
the Paleolithic Era which was from 2.5
million years ago to 10 000 years ago
and let's try to you know make some
assumptions some educated guesses about
what foods were being eaten
predominantly during that time frame and
so uh when you're when when someone
adopts the paleo diet or the modern
interpretation
they're going to be eating mostly fruits
vegetables lean meats fish eggs nuts and
seeds and in a way you could argue that
the paleo diet is more defined by what
you don't eat than what you do so people
who consume or adhere to a paleo diet
generally don't eat foods that became
more widely available with the Advent of
modern farming practices so they
basically would avoid things like grains
legumes and dairy products and then of
course you know processed foods with a
bunch of added sugars and things like
that so so it's a pretty limited scope
of Whole Foods that paleo diet or select
from and there are entire food groups
that get excluded
one thing that I think is worth noting
is that the uh the idea that we can
create kind of the ideal or optimal
hunter-gatherer diet
it does rest on a lot of assumptions and
generalizations and if you ask yourself
and consult with the literature what do
hunter-gatherer populations actually eat
the answer is that it depends and it
depends a lot there is a tremendous
amount of variation when you compare the
diet of one hunter-gatherer population
to another so there's a great paper by
ponzer and colleagues and you write you
might recall that name Ponce because
we've talked about his research many
times on the show but in this paper they
were looking at the dietary patterns of
a large number of hunter-gatherer
populations in this case I believe it
was
265 distinct hunter-gatherer populations
and they're kind of interested in saying
okay what do these people eat and the
short answer is whatever they can get
their hands on basically
um so what they found was that there was
a tremendous amount of variation When
comparing one dietary pattern to another
that variation was geographically
clustered and generally speaking it was
dictated by latitude right so you could
think of
you know if I were a hunter-gatherer
living near the equator what would be
accessible to me that would be very very
different from if I were all the way up
near the north pole trying to you know
trying to uh hunt and gather food and so
as latitude changes as geography changes
dietary patterns change in
hunter-gatherer populations because they
must food availability is simply
different but when it comes to trying to
paint with uh a broad brush and say you
know here's the optimal hunter-gatherer
diet that humans evolved to eat it's
very very difficult to do that the
variation is immense and if you just
look at a simple characteristic like
what percentage of the diet comes from
plant Foods versus animal Foods when you
look at this large collection of
hunter-gatherer populations you see that
I mean there are some under-gatherer
populations where almost all of the food
is coming from plants and there are some
where almost all of the food is coming
from animal-based sources and of course
every everything in between so I I do
think that we should resist the urge to
assume
that there is a singular kind of
standard human hunter-gatherer diet
because uh what our evolutionary history
tells us is that humans are very
adaptable and we can adapt to the food
availability of whatever environment we
happen to be in within reason of course
we have a limited capacity for
adaptation but
um but yeah humans have thrived on a
wide range of diets in our evolutionary
history and it's important to recognize
that whenever you talk about the paleo
diet now the paleo diet from my
perspective there are some some
advantages or some upsides if you were
to look at the diet you know if you were
to talk to someone who's on a Paleo diet
and just say all right write down one
you had for breakfast lunch and dinner
you would look through the foods and
you'd say well okay this is great you're
eating a lot of really nutritious foods
with plenty of micronutrients and that's
excellent
um but what you will find is that they
are excluding some entire food groups
which means that there might be a
possibility that you're missing out on
and you know one or two key
micronutrients here and there generally
speaking we don't want to exclude entire
food groups unless we must now sometimes
there are situations where we have to
exclude large you know groups of
different food products because of some
medical reason or it might be
um you know a decision that is you know
driven by an ethical decision or a
religious decision to exclude certain
foods but from a purely nutritional
perspective we'd love to have the
biggest menu possible we don't want to
be arbitrarily excluding food groups
unless we must
and so when it comes to the paleo diet
you know when you look at things like
whole grain products or legumes or or
dairy products we are kind of
arbitrarily excluding some food groups
and a large number of food products that
that do have something to bring to the
table in terms of nutrient coverage so
um the paleo diet on the up you know on
the Advantage side or the pro side you
could say yeah there's a lot of really
nutritious foods that can be
incorporated here and you're not
necessarily locked into a set
macronutrient distribution although I
will say in practice it seems that a lot
of people on Paleo diets do air toward
lower carbohydrate intake but but like I
said generally speaking
um you know there are some really
nutritious Foods in the mix some
flexibility in terms of macronutrient
distribution however because it's
arbitrarily uh excluding some of those
food groups um I I struggle to see it as
a a optimal kind of default mode of
eating but without question there are a
great many folks who kind of consume
like a typical Western diet who would
meaningfully improve their dietary
pattern by switching from their kind of
typical Western diet to a paleo diet I
would not uh I would not push back
against that contention I think for a
lot of folks simply incorporating more
of these nutritious Foods would be a
beneficial thing but the thing with the
paleo diet is that it just has some
restrictions that are a bit arbitrary
they're not fully necessary they're
difficult to defend from a nutritional
perspective and ultimately they're just
taking choices and flexibility off the
table
all right now moving on I want to talk
about the carnivore diet this is the
last diet that I'm going to discuss in
today's episode
um now I was on a a web series with Omar
esoph about a year or two ago and I
talked a little bit about the carnivore
diet
um and we were talking about it in the
context of ancient warriors Omar did a
really entertaining series about ancient
warriors and how they might have eaten
how they might have trained and things
like that if you haven't seen it I would
encourage you to check it out it's very
very entertaining Omar is an extremely
entertaining dude so it's good stuff
um but in that uh you know we had a chat
about the carnivore diet as it pertained
to a particular group of ancient
warriors and one of the questions that
came up was very basic it was you know
can you survive on a carnivore diet and
the answer is yes it seems so
um as long as it is a very thoughtfully
constructed carnivore diet
um you know I I think a a lot of folks
when they think of the carnivore diet
they think about just eating beef you
know ground beef and steak and water and
salt and there are people who claim to
do that
and I I simply don't get it I I don't
know why you would opt into a list of
foods that small
uh and I think that the nutrient
coverage is severely limited on that
type of diet I struggle to understand
how someone would truly adhere to that
for a long time scale without
supplementation and not
um and not essentially suffer the
consequences of some pretty pretty
notable micronutrient deficiencies
um you know I I think that if you are
someone who is you know seeing people
talk about an all beef diet and all
you're eating is literally the muscle
tissue of cows
I could not
um urge against following that diet uh
more strongly than than this I mean
unequivocally that is a terrible diet to
only eat the muscle the muscle tissue of
cows if you're on a ground beef only and
steak only diet from a nutritional
perspective uh that that is a truly
terrible diet and I've not said that
about any of the other fad diets we've
talked about this far so I hope that
I've gained a little bit of credibility
in the sense that I I haven't been just
trying to rail on these diets but there
are very few redeemable qualities
whatsoever of a diet that exclusively
leans on beef now you can have a beef
heavy carnivore diet that is much more
compatible with a healthy dietary
pattern and the way you would do that
the way that is relatively common or
popular among carnivore influencers
is to focus on eating a variety of
different animal tissues so not just
eating uh the muscle tissue of cows not
just eating ground beef and steak but
also eating a variety of different organ
meats and there are some organ meats
that are very very dense and very rich
in micronutrients so it would be unfair
to just say that all carnivore diets are
just like steak only diets and that they
you know have these massive shortcomings
with micronutrients there are some folks
who do what they call nose to tail
carnivore dieting where they're
consuming a lot of different tissues
um you know rather than just muscle
tissue and like I said there are
definitely some some organ tissues that
contain a high density of a wide range
of micronutrients so um a beef only diet
is truly a terrible idea and there are
no redeeming qualities of such a diet
that could not be found from a much more
suitable much more effective diet uh the
kind of nose to tail carnivore approach
not really my thing in terms of my food
preferences and and the things that I
find palatable but at the very least it
does open up some doors for additional
micronutrient coverage
um of course one thing that you have to
ask yourself is why am I excluding
plants from my diet
a lot of times
people who talk about carnivore diets
are really uh
really exaggerating the impact of what
would be called anti-nutrients
um so there's a lot of folks who kind of
push this narrative that plants have all
these toxins and the plants are trying
to kill you when you eat them and
therefore plants are bad for you I mean
if you're really making an
evidence-based argument that vegetables
are are truly bad for human beings
we just don't see the literature the
same way uh and we clearly don't uh see
the hierarchy of evidence the same way
usually people will look at these little
kind of mechanistic studies or just kind
of theoretical extrapolations well if
that's an anti-nutrient then what would
happen if you had this much of it it's
really taking these little tiny granules
of Truth and spinning up these um
extrapolations and these exaggerations
that would lead one to say oh yeah you
should avoid all plant-based food
sources and uh it's extremely difficult
to defend that position when you look at
the broader literature so
um you know can you get a lot of you
know protein essential fatty acids
suitable micronutrient coverage from a
really well-rounded carnivore diet it's
possible but it's important to note that
you really are excluding a lot of very
high quality food sources for
essentially no reason at all um you know
a lot of folks will say well I'm doing
the carnivore diet because I had
um you know a really high number of food
allergies or food sensitivities I do uh
empathize with that situation I I truly
understand you know the the premise
there
but for people in that situation there
are a lot of folks right now on social
media saying if you have a lot of food
sensitivities or allergies you just eat
steak the rest of your life uh that's
first of all terrible advice and second
of all not the best way to approach this
there are better ways what you would
want to do in my opinion is get with a
registered dietitian and try an
Elimination Diet what you would do is
for a short period of time you would
Whittle down your food list to a very
restricted list of foods uh you know
very Bare Bones diet but then you would
systematically reintroduce foods and try
to figure out how do I work back to a
sustainable long-term dietary pattern
that doesn't aggravate my food allergies
or sensitivities you'd want to do that
under the direction of a qualified
professional
um but you know when we talk about these
really restrictive diets you know maybe
if you're doing an Elimination Diet you
might have a super restrictive pattern
for a couple weeks at a time but this
idea that you're just going to eat
ground beef for the rest of your life is
is really not a suitable solution even
in that particular application
um one other thing I want to mention
with the carnivore diet
I just think this is interesting and I
haven't heard anyone really talk about
it there's a lot of chatter in the
carnivore world that you know um first
of all you know these carnivore diets
are are totally
um you know if you're eating nose to
tail as they always say uh you know
you're good to go plenty of
micronutrients this is how you know
plenty of hunter-gatherer populations
would get their micronutrients is by
eating you know eyeballs and skin and
things like that I did come across a
paper where they were looking at dietary
patterns in East Greenland uh in a
hunter-gatherer population and they're
looking at data from 1936 to 1937 and
how this hunter-gatherer population was
eating and more specifically they were
looking at how they were getting vitamin
C in an area where there really wasn't a
lot of what we would call terrestrial
vegetation not a lot of land-based
plants that you could grow and eat for
vitamin C content and so I'm just going
to read this quote from from the from
the paper the main conclusions of the
present study are the important role of
algae consumption in greenlandic
traditional dietary pattern to avoid
scurvy and that Foods traditionally seen
as important sources of vitamin C like
ice from Seals and narwhal skin played a
minor role in meeting the vitamin C
requirements so basically what they did
was they reanalyzed some of this
nutritional data from several decades
ago and said you know we always assumed
that that these individuals were getting
most of their vitamin C from seal
eyeballs and getting it from narwhal
skin one of the things that they were
talking about in the paper is
I mean if you're getting a lot if this
group of individuals was getting a huge
portion of their vitamin C from seal
eyeballs that is a lot of seals that you
need to be able to to hunt uh over a
given time frame and so one of the
things that tipped them off into looking
more deeply into algae consumption was
they were just like I mean from a
feasibility perspective how are you
getting this many C uh seal eyeballs
um you know in order to sustain the
dietary needs of this population of
hunter-gatherer so
um I think in some cases uh there's a a
tendency to assume that yeah this nose
to tail thing is how everybody does it
no one no one in their right mind would
be eating vegetation whether it's sea
vegetation or terrestrial vegetation see
when I say sea vegetation I mean you
know algae seaweed things like that
um so I just wanted to highlight in uh
what I found to be an interesting
observation which is that even in
populations that have traditionally been
assumed to be almost fully
carnivorous in terms of their dietary
pattern it's very possible that they
have been leaning on things like seaweed
and algae for some micronutrient
coverage more than we might anticipate
now big big caveat
I have just opened myself up to a world
of pain I have no interest in going Toe
to Toe with uh with someone whose entire
life is built around the carnivore diet
digging into this kind of population
level research about who which of these
hunter-gatherer populations is you know
fully carnivorous and which ones are not
um that that's not something that
interests me I just wanted to point this
out because I I found it to be an
interesting observation like I said I
don't contest the idea that you could
formulate a carnivore diet that you know
theoretically with enough access to
various organ tissues could sustain and
support human life I don't contest that
but what I would say is boy that's a
hard way to eat if you if you have
access to a grocery store there are some
more flexible and some more sustainable
ways to put together a dietary pattern
so I would just caution people against
you know like I said I'm not a big fan
of you know just arbitrarily taking
entire food groups off the menu when it
comes to the carnivore carnivore diet
you're taking almost all the food groups
off the menu in a way that's really
arbitrary and most of the justifications
for it just really fall flat at face
value they're really not compatible with
the evidence
one thing that I find interesting about
the carnivore diet
is some folks have started to adapt it a
little bit
um and and I saw this you know back back
in the day around 2012 2013 I would
follow the paleo diet a little more
closely and I started to see these
iterations where people would just tweak
it and say yeah paleo except for the
thing I really like I'm going to throw
that in there too
um so I have seen people who have said
like yeah I don't necessarily call it
carnivore but I'm going to call it like
animal based but I'm gonna eat meat and
you know a bunch of organ tissues and
dairy products and honey and fruit and
at a certain point I'm just looking at
this dietary pattern I'm like are you
sure that this isn't just like a
gluten-free diet from someone who hates
vegetables because it starts to kind of
get there
um and it's funny because like from a
nomenclature perspective I think it's
kind of silly because I'm like dude
you're just not you're just not doing a
carnivore diet anymore I don't know why
you're fighting so hard to make this
seem like a carnivore adjacent diet like
you just ate like half a watermelon you
know like it's not really a carnivore
kind of thing so from a nomenclature
perspective I think it's kind of silly
but from a dietary pattern perspective
it's an upgrade and so like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say like hey don't
do that I mean if someone tells me you
know I was eating beef only but now I'm
eating you know beef and organ meat and
dairy and honey and fruit then I'm like
whatever dude perfect like it's an
upgrade I'll take it and that's usually
how I view things with the carnivore
diet
um usually people who are on a carnivore
diet I'll be completely candid They
Don't Really reach out to me because
they have self-selected out of the
content I make uh you know carnivore
diet
content is like its own little niche and
uh I'm not one of the producers in that
Niche so I don't get a lot of folks who
come to me and say hey Eric I'm on a
carnivore diet what should I do it has
happened but not not much
um but in those scenarios if someone
comes up to me and says Eric I'm on a
carnivore diet what do you think I
should do
um the first thing I try to do is figure
out what got us here why are we on a
carnivore diet and obviously that's
going to dictate the path forward but my
general approach usually when people
have
gone to the lengths of adopting a
carnivore diet there's already some
pretty extreme nutritional perspectives
at play there and I don't want to rock
the boat too much and so what I'll say
is okay well can we go from carnivore to
like ketogenic with just like a couple
other like food sources in the mix maybe
you're willing to do like some Dairy
some fruit you know and we're still like
pretty keto but we're working in some
berries and we've got some dairy
products like can we do that you know
and sometimes people say yeah I can get
on board with that and then you know
they start to say okay well you know
eating more than steak I haven't fallen
apart yet this is fine and then you know
you can say okay well how do you feel
about the paleo diet right and so like
we will still be eating like the meat
and the organs and the the fruit and
stuff but we'll mix in some other things
you know and so if you can work someone
um you know kind of as a sequential
process and go from carnivore to
ketogenic with a limited food selection
and then work your way toward toward
something like a paleo diet you don't
have to like totally disrupt some of
those concerns they might have about
food source selection you can kind of
ease them into a dietary pattern that is
a lot more flexible and you know going
back
to those those criteria we talked about
earlier we can check more boxes if
someone comes to me and says Eric I only
eat ground beef and steak and you know I
put some salt on it sometimes
when we look at those healthy diet
indicator criteria we're not really
checking any of the boxes you know we we
have a lot of ground to make up and so
when I think about transitioning someone
or helping nudge them from one very
restrictive dietary pattern to a less
restrictive pattern to a less
restrictive pattern to a less
restrictive pattern what I'm really
trying to do is say can we create a
pathway by which we are going to become
more compliant I guess with those
healthy diet indicator criteria we don't
have to go a hundred percent check every
single box but we really want to be
checking some of those boxes you know
and some of them are more important than
others for sure but that usually is the
process I take if someone like I said is
is on a a car a carnivore diet that is
beef only you have to appreciate that
going into that they're going to have
some pretty extreme perspectives about
food and if you say well actually you
should be on a raw food vegan diet
instead
um that's gonna require them to
literally reverse everything they've
ever thought about food that's too too
big of a jump to make for most people
um now it's possible that they went to
the extremes of the carnivore diet
because they they kind of have a
personality and a temperament that
latches on to its extremes so maybe they
do want to jump from the most carnivore
diet possible to the most vegan diet
possible you never know uh but generally
speaking it can be I think for most
folks a little bit easier to do a
sequence of nudges and say okay let's
try to incorporate a few things at a
time here which like I said is is pretty
pretty similar to what we would see with
a medical professional who might be
overseeing that process of doing an
Elimination Diet followed by a
reintroduction process you know in this
case it's more psychologically making
sure that you're not biting off more
than you can chew and just kind of
easing back into a more flexible dietary
pattern that's ultimately going to be
more compatible with a health related
literature
so uh really quick I want to just do a
little summary to wrap up here when it
comes to low carb diets there are plenty
of great applications but there are also
some applications that are far more
restrictive than they need to be so
whenever you're looking at any
particular version of a low carb diet
you want to look at it and say first of
all are there enough carbs to support
the physical activity that is important
to me that's really going to dictate how
many carbs you really need on a
day-to-day basis from there you want to
think about is this diet pattern
consistent with my preferences is it
checking a lot of the boxes that we
associate with a generally healthy
dietary pattern you want to take a
closer look at is this something that is
really suitable for me is it going to be
sustainable and feasible and does it fit
my preferences uh reasonably well
from that point you then want to look at
the specific restrictions that are
implemented make sure that they're not
too restrictive for your lifestyle and
also make sure that they're not
completely arbitrary in nature and as I
mentioned previously if there are any
elements of the dietary approach that
that required require you to arbitrarily
eliminate entire food groups or to
really micromanage glycemic index values
or to continuously monitor your glucose
levels those are probably approaches
that are worth skipping because it
probably means you're going to be
investing a lot of time and effort and
worry and you're probably not going to
get a lot back from that investment so
these types of low carb diet approaches
as we've discussed they take many many
forms right it could be the Zone diet
the Atkins diet the South Beach Diet a
generic low carb diet paleo keto
carnivore you name it there's a lot of
different diets that fall under this
low-carb umbrella some of them you know
a basic low carb diet can be totally
suitable for a large number of people
but there are some applications of these
low carb diets that get really
arbitrarily restrictive they might be a
bit problematic in terms of eliminating
really high quality food sources they
might make it harder to get all the
micronutrients you need and they might
just be so difficult to sustain that it
really negatively impacts quality of
life so those are the things you want to
keep in mind when you're looking at some
of these popular diets
now finally before I end this episode I
hope you'll afford me the opportunity to
make a Shameless sales pitch on behalf
of macro factor which is the diet app
that Greg and I co-developed with a very
talented team of colleagues as you're
considering the wide variety of diet
strategies that you might Implement in
the new year I just want to reassure
people that whatever you might be
getting into from a nutritional
perspective macro Factor can absolutely
facilitate whatever you're planning to
do first and foremost macro factor is a
remarkably fast and efficient food
logger it is remarkably convenient as a
food logger it has a huge verified
databases of foods that you can trust it
also has extremely efficient processes
by which you can add custom Foods custom
recipes and you can even share your
recipes with others so whatever your
food Choice preferences are uh macro
Factor can certainly handle it now
within macro Factor we have coached
programs that give you uh you know
different macro programs and there are
several settings that range all the way
from ketogenic diets to low-fat diets
and within each of those macro programs
you have tons of flexibility you can
choose four different levels of protein
intake based on your preferences but if
you want even greater flexibility you
can Branch out from the coached programs
and get into what we call collaborative
mode which is still coached in terms of
your calorie targets but you have a lot
more flexibility with your day-to-day
macro distributions or if you want even
more flexibility you can do a fully
manual program that is customized
exactly to your liking one other thing I
should note is macro Factor the food log
actually takes the form of a timeline so
what that means is if you're interested
in doing time restricted feeding it's
very very easy to implement a wide range
of food timing strategy so it could be
time restricted feeding or you might
just want to have a really consistent
pattern pertaining to meal timing so if
you have any time dependent nutrition
strategies macro factor is very well
suited for that and since I mentioned
time restricted feeding
which is often falls under the umbrella
of intermittent fasting macro Factor
also allows you to specify fasting days
so if you are doing any type of fasting
related protocol macro Factor can be
used to facilitate that as well so in
summary macro factor is your diet
sidekick it provides all the guidance
all the support all the analytics that
you need without infringing on your
ability to make your own decisions and
chart your own course toward your
fitness goals so if you want to learn
more about macro Factor head over to
macro factorapp.com the app is available
for Android and iPhone devices so that
does it thank you for joining me for
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast part two of this
discussion will be coming shortly if you
happen to be celebrating any holidays
this time of year the stronger by
science family sends the best possible
Vibes to you and and your loved ones
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you